i think people people are losing their
minds because of living in their phones
yes because they don't have real world
experiences so let's let's let's uh do a
w
we're doing a weird segway show today
but this one um i'm greatly offended by
i don't understand that actually i'm
super not offended by this there's a guy
named ali london who has come out as
trans korean and he got surgery i guess
i don't know if he got surgery but his
eyes like
so uh um i thought it was funny because
it's like the supermodel fox lift is
that what it's called yeah all those ch
i don't want to be a jerk but girl we
all know ben shapiro says live your
truth ali and then people are making fun
of him so this guy ali london says this
is my new official flag for being a
non-binary person who identifies as
korean thank you for the overwhelming
support it was so hard for me to come
out as them they core ian this guy's
trolling like sure he's saying his
pronouns are core and ian so like
that's like all these people that come
to the italian uh christmas party at
mamas and they're like oh lasagna hey
we're part of the family we're like hey
and they are part of the family only
they're not look at it look at this this
sweetie put up he penned it my
transition story and how i became korean
you know what i find really funny about
this the reason why this one really
really like i i first of all i'm i'm all
for it um i think everybody should want
to be korean of course um you know so
i'm like i'm sitting here like all right
but it's just i don't know if he's being
honest if it's a big prank it probably
is
but the idea that someone who's a white
british guy wants so desperately to be
korean and he's like he does a video
where he's like say oh like oh my god
i'm like dude i i actually my mom would
make bulgogi when i was growing up he
wants to be korean more than i do i'm
actually part korean and i don't even
speak the language at all and this is
some white dude in london who like
wants to be more korean
it's an identity crisis it's not real
and people are mentally ill
we're all like
this is a mental illness crisis that
we've never seen anything like this
before it's like they've
opened all the doors of you know insane
asylums it's like the scarecrow and the
batman movie when he's just released the
drug on the people that is what the
phone's done tmc says british influencer
identifies as korean after 18 surgeries
to look like bts singer i'm sorry man
this is a guy he's committed i i think
there's a lot of people who like there's
trans-racial is like it clearly has been
a thing for a while with rachel dolezal
and people like sean king where they're
just claiming to be a certain race when
they're clearly not
and anyway
so you get people like this and it's
it's the weirdest thing to me because
i'm like
i i had a bunch of like white
nationalist dudes tell me that i
wouldn't understand
the alt-right because i have no identity
they're like tim poole is like mixed
race so he doesn't actually have
anything you mean you're an american mot
like most of us like most people like
how many people are like i'm irish and
it's like well you're also german and
italian a bunch of stuff i'm italian uh
lebanese irish and scottish but i was
raised by a full italian woman whose
parents and family were all off the boat
and i i feel italian because you were
raised italian but i ain't i am an
american mutt and when we go to other
countries what are you oh i'm irish
they're like you were oh you were born
in ireland they're like no and they're
like god americans are stupid
you guys are so dumb
yep well um what do we say to this guy
that guy's like crazy and amazing all at
the same time
i'm i'm here i'm i'm for it because um
i don't i i i we might get in trouble
for even talking about it but i don't
see the difference between this or any
other identity like if you just want to
assert i think it was zoobee who was
saying that race is a social construct
because if you said he made a good point
about this i i don't think it's fair to
say completely but he said if you told
people that obama was white they would
say you're nuts if you said he was black
they would say of course he is even
though he's the exact same amount of
white as he has black you know so
probably to people in africa they look
at obama as probably more white because
he's not you know he's not the same as
them he's he's mixed race that's a
really good point by zooby so you look
at something like this and he's like
okay well gender
like biological sex hard physical
differences between the biological
biological sexes but you could have
somebody born in korea
who could probably pass for white or
someone who's born in france who could
pass for korean i've i've known a lot of
people in my life who are just like
regular white people and they were like
french and they looked like they had
some asian in them like no completely
white oh yeah my my husband has like
i thought he had native american and it
turns out he's full viking he went and
got a dna test i was like that totally
makes sense you nordic giant the celts
were all over the place they came from
like the the north northwest europe and
they went to like east asia they went to
like anatolia and past turkey they went
down to spain like they were everywhere
we're all humans and colonizing is
simply conquering and that's what human
beings do we kick each other's asses and
we take each other's stuff
that is what war is so when people are
anti-war i'm like yeah i'm anti-war and
when you don't gloat how you're taking
all their stuff so what we've been in
the middle east forever congratulations
everyone we took all their things just
say it that's why you're there you know
what i mean but with this thing remember
the cat lady with all the surgeries and
everyone made fun of her for years
she was ahead of everyone there's this
like social life that turned herself
into a cat
she
was the original so well there was the
there was the trans cat
trans female cat i i'm genuinely trying
to get this correct
there was an individual who was born
male
who got surgery to look like a tiger
and then came out as transgender as well
and then the sad story ultimately ended
up committing suicide
so i i think one of the issues is that
people who have uh in many respects an
identity crisis
and they can never figure out who they
are i don't think that in many of these
circumstances like this this guy
look at this photo right here from from
what what's his name london ali ali
london or whatever this face is making
where he's like doing his fists it's a
caricature of korean people like i don't
think he's ever actually gone to korea
and met a korean person because they
don't act like these cartoon characters
there there was a a viral tick tock
where a guy
was
talking to the camera and he was making
this really creepy motions where he was
like bouncing like this as he talked and
doing like that acting like a cartoon
character from a disney movie
you know what i think it is
i think a lot of people when they grow
up and they're completely entrenched in
seeing some kind of behavior
their brain
adds that to like this is what adults do
that's how they act so when you get a
guy who's doing these face things
he spends too much time too much time
watching fiction like this caricature of
of korean pop culture where they it's
not how people act nobody acts that way
could you imagine if americans were
walking around like nsync and dancing
and singing with each other all the time
it's not like real life okay but they
they think it is so now he's like in
order to be normal i have to be that how
old is he
24 i think okay and this is our
generation's fault we failed the
children people our age had kids and we
told them all this bull crap you could
be anything johnny you're a winner every
moment anything you dream and this is
the result we had a chance between 2006
and nine to set the record straight and
get people to unify but then we gave
power to obama and let him
act like the new messiah everyone it's
almost like you know i never see this
people laugh for me to speak out against
to be fair what do we do mccain
it's like it was just it was awesome
power to a president was the problem
because we shouldn't have done that
yeah she was fun to watch it was like
giving we gave power to a president for
the for the last time like it was the
bit last straw you cannot give power to
one guy to run this country it's too
much of a big of a job well i think i
think americans did come together and
then they vilified everyone for doing it
in 2016 they all
voted
for donald trump except for me i didn't
do it but my gay cousin did and so did
his partner and you know what voted for
trump in 2016. uh 2016 and in uh this
last election my gay cousin hi if you're
watching made a gaze for trump sign all
rainbow and sparkly put a floodlight on
it in the south side of chicago it was
like bring the hate crime baby bring the
hate crime he was like watching out the
window like i'm gonna get them and i'm
so proud of him because he's all like i
reject lgbtq community it's been
hijacked i reject
broken glass and all this stuff that
they're telling me is okay and burning
down buildings and i'm like my cousin is
so based i was very proud of him that's
punk rock yeah raised mormon
gay as gay can be and was gay for trump
i love you it feels like
we had a chance in 2006 to nine again
these years for me it was very uh
there's a growing period where we could
have ended the war and we didn't and now
the young generation is like oh this is
okay then i'm just i don't care about
anything because if that's okay
then this world has no meaning
i i wanted to end it yeah i was like was
it day two yeah get out of that that's
what one of the things that woke me up
and that's when i started digging i was
like wait he wanted to end the war that
obama lied to me about and then i
researched and found out it was all lie
you know you know i think you're right
about they see the war and they're like
you know nothing matters
my view of it is
you grew up in a world where
like you're literally born into a
country at war occupying the middle east
and
it's it's like how do you argue morality
how do you for for all of us who
experience 911 there was a shock to our
emotions and so they made that case and
a lot of people bought into it and a lot
of people eventually said we've had
enough this was wrong it should never
have happened the aumf needs to be you
know officially rescinded but for these
people who were born into it the united
states has always been the country that
just does what it wants goes over there
and
just kind of screws it up so what
happens is their moral compass is just
like
a corkscrew it's not pointing in any one
direction it's just like nothing matters
i can be anything i'm a tiger korean and
i'm you know the the moon has made it
through bricks burn building like crazy
things
the kids who grew up in the country they
were like a lot of these young kids who
are now out with antifa they may have
been uh i mean it's been it's been
almost 20 years since 9 11. so you have
these kids who are
like toddlers when it happened with no
memory with no experience of it being
born into a world where they're told
over and over again the u.s takes what
it wants so what do they do they walk
around with bricks they smash windows
they take whatever they want who's gonna
tell them they're wrong it's because we
told parents they couldn't punish their
children anymore
i'm not for abusing children but when i
was bad
my parents and my
old italian grandma should take off her
church shoe get that hard heel and be
like come up and i was like oh don't do
that again i learned a lot of lessons
what was it called
chancellor that's right yeah
the flip-flop from the grandma and
cheese it was not a flip-flop it was a
hard one the mexican catholic italian
catholic
she was not messing around she's like
jesus saw
he saw what you did
like we had a
wooden spoon with a hole in the middle
so it'd leave a the welt would grow
where the hole was but i didn't get it
much i was like the first generation
where did you get it much just because i
didn't speak up i i played within the
lines but also it was like you were
saying we were part like the beginning
of the generations of people did not hit
your kids not that i don't advocate for
hitting kids i don't like it i don't
think he should but like i i was like my
brother i'm calling child service you
know that kind of like
i didn't have that my grandma was born
in the 1920s she was rosie the riveter
her brother served in world war ii and
was in a concentration camp as a pow
with like
uh the tattoo all of that she was having
none of that you're calling dcfs that
didn't exist in my house and it was
never to be said and i lived
think about this way you get a kid who
grows up and
we're not talking about abusing kids
we're talking about a spanking yeah no
no abuse is horrible but if i tell my
mom she's the b word and i did and then
my mom's like what
bop which i deserved and then i sat
there like oh maybe i should never call
my mom a page again and that's what i
did it's i think there's a line i think
there's a lot of research that shows
that corporal punishment i guess they
call it is not particularly effective
but i have to question what's the
research going to show on when you have
a bunch of kids who grew up without
punishment at all or it was very much
like okay okay honey okay i'll buy you
ice cream if you calm down
what's gonna happen to those people
they're older and they're communists and
they're throwing bricks through windows
true like when i went to school when we
had problems with each other we met
behind the tennis courts and i mean
bloodbath fought it out like there was
consequences to like things people don't
do that anymore there's no like boxing
matches anymore i guess you just go into
dueling near a city and break out a
building and light it on fire and loot
your nearest nike could you imagine
being back in the day and it's like you
know someone's tweeting at you and then
you're like sir i challenge you to a
duel and it's like we're going to end
this twitter flame war once and for all
someone dies how crazy you get like you
have like experience and it goes up if
you win the duel no just pistols at dawn
twitter beef twitter of beef be ended
that's right no sir i will not debate
you pistols that's done that's why i
think everyone should be locked and
loaded we should all open carry every
single american citizen how many people
will be like you know what i'm gonna
carjack that car no cause everyone in
that car is locked and loaded i truly
believe
that we've fallen this is the map
this is the craziest thing to me how
many how many times i've seen like on
twitter there's a dude who's trying to
violently rob someone with like
aggravated assault and then someone
comes out like there's a video where
it's like a guy draws a gun on someone
and then a woman pulls a gun from her
purse and she shoots him and i see
people on the left being like she didn't
have to kill him you know she could have
done this and it's like
that's the mentality that i think leads
to ruin yeah i love the criminals the
criminals who are attacking and
oppressing
should not have been harmed in any way
and it's like well hold on first of all
i wish it didn't happen but if you walk
up to someone point a gun to their head
and someone puts you down because of it
like we're trying to stop that violence
and we're acting in defense of others
but how many stories have we heard where
it's like a dude's running from the cops
and he pulls a gun how about that guy uh
in in it wasn't atlanta he turns the
taser and fires it at the cops
and so the cop fires in defense and
they're like arrest the cop oh wow yeah
that's
i saw a post i saw a post on facebook
some guy said
uh chauvin is finally being locked up
and it's about time justice doesn't
always happen blah blah blah and i
responded with
don't forget about the chaos the
violence and the destruction if it
wasn't for the terror and the violence
those jurors may have actually let
chauvin go
never forget
never forget it is better that 10
innocent people suffer than one guilty
person escape so saith otto von bismarck
and the person liked it
i was i was trying to make a point like
i was trying to make a point
that like
do you see yourself for who you are it
is better that ten
guilty persons escaped than one innocent
suffer but the left today is absolutely
adopted they would love the innocent to
suffer if it means one guilty person
you're asking people to look in a mirror
at their true like in the never-ending
story when atreyu has to
face his true self in the mirror gate
and he looks and it drives some men mad
i've spent 20 years in therapy i've been
looking at my reflection for a long time
i think a lot of people should be doing
this and if they did maybe our world
wouldn't be so horrible but no one does
because if we train everyone just lie to
yourself and say you're a good person
there's hardly any good people like
humanity what we want to do every day we
want to be selfish i cook delicious food
and there's a crispy piece of chicken
and my selfish brain goes i want that i
don't want to give that to my husband
and then i have to override that selfish
worthless behavior and give him the good
crispy chicken and i'm like that
shouldn't be so hard but it's hard i
want the chicken you're a good person
right that is that good where my first
thought is i want everything good for me
to define good good subjective because
you think about it and you decide to
share the definition of courage is not
being fearless right it's overcoming
your fear so you look at these other
people and they don't have that
self-control of course we're all selfish
inside what we're seeing with the latest
iteration of this this mainstream left
is
overt authoritarianism look at look at
what happened in minnesota
these people genuinely thought that it
was better that all of the innocent
people of the city suffer with bricks
through windows and fires with armed men
escorting jurors in terror into the
building so that one man would not
escape but we as more libertarian types
take the opposite view it is better that
the guilty people escape to preserve the
production of the innocent we are ned
stark and that lost his head i think it
was ben franklin who made a really
important point it might have been
jefferson about why we must err on the
side of defending liberty and that means
guilty people escape because if at some
point the innocent person knows that
they will not receive justice the system
can't sustain itself because the
innocent stop participating yep yeah you
get mass non-compliance from people who
fear no matter what i do you will attack
me i will defend myself that's why i
don't like to travel that's why this is
the first time i've traveled thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you